Morano who believes that eric zemmour is not of the extreme right,
we also remember eric ciotti who does not hesitate to choose
zemmour rather than macron in the hypothesis of a second round,
which means that the cordon sanitary between the
right and the extreme right is more and more fragile.
Do you care about that?
Well,
that explains quite well why I am no longer in the
party of which Mrs. Morano and the representative.
And after all,
it can be explained,
I consider that I participated in the
creation of the ump and I came to the right,
probably for the moment by the figure of the general of Gaulle.
I still have a hard time hearing someone explain to you
that Marshal Pétain really wanted to save the French allies,
right?
Foreigners,
I have.
I have a lot of trouble,
I, I.
Finally when I tell you,
I'm in a lot of trouble,
it pisses me off and in anger that you have no idea
about while I stay calm because I never get angry.
But I don't consider anyone who says that to truly
belong to or be looked upon by Republicans as basically,
not being far right,
that's not true.
The question she would have never asked herself with jacques chirac?
That's not true.
She would have never landed with Nicolas Sarkozy either.
Well,
I think that I do not deny zemmour the right
to be a candidate and to develop his ideas.
It's democracy.
I believe in it.
I don't deny the right of Republicans to have their election strategy.
I say that I don't like it.